monsieur le président bien venu vous
dire que votre audition était très
attendu c'est pas un scoop puisque
évidemment nous sommes tous aujourd'hui
en attente d'informations pour cette
fameuse réforme ferroviaire qui devrait
être examiné au sénat première semaine
de juillet il nous faut donc dès à
présent puisque nous avons peu de temps
à voir sur cette réforme toutes les
précisions que vous pourrez nous donner
et vous savez que dans cette commission
le sujet de l'aménagement du territoire
de la mobilité durable sont des sujets
majeurs de cette commission et par
conséquent cette réforme pour nous est
de la plus grande importance
alors nous savons que quelques grandes
lignes que nous avons pu avoir laisse
encore beaucoup de points à clarifier
que des arbitrages moins nécessaire que
la réforme du modèle social est
importante et bien sûr que le transport
ferroviaire constitue pour l'avenir
notre pays un élément extrêmement
important et bien sûr cette réforme
non seulement elle était absolument
indispensable mais peut-être qu'elle
constitue une des dernières chances de
sauver le rail français
on sait que le déficit aujourd'hui est
d'environ 40 milliards et que si nous ne
faisons rien il augmente de 2 milliards
et demi tous les ans et donc il faut
absolument que nous puissions arrêter
cette hémorragie
j'ajoute que le nombre d'élus locaux
sont en attente des attentes fortes et
parfois regrette que ses attentes mais
aucune réponse et on voit avec
inquiétude des lignes capillaire de fret
ou des lignes secondaires de voyageurs
qui sont dans un tel état qu'on pense
qu'elles vont disparaître non bien sûr
nous avons des spécialistes dans notre
commission particulier notre rapporteur
monsieur michel teston qui ne manqueront
pas de vous interroger et bien entendu
si louis peuvent se libérer je
pense que nous verrons aussi ils
viennent tout à l'heure par fait ce ne
sont pas les seuls et donc j'espère que
cette audition permettra d'avoir donc
toutes les informations nécessaires
avant de nous engager dans notre travail
de parlementaire j'ajoute tout de suite
pour mes collègues que à la fin du sujet
principal de cette audition que la
réforme ferroviaire
si vous le voulez bien monsieur le
président on dire en deux mots des
problèmes de quai et de rames ter mais
nous le ferons une fois que nous aurons
terminé l'audition concernant la réforme
sur vire monsieur le président sans plus
attendre je vous donne la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
bonjour mesdames et messieurs merci
beaucoup de cette opportunité que vous
m'offrez de m'exprimer devant vous sur
la réforme ferroviaire je veux tout de
suite précisé que la réforme ferroviaire
c'est le projet du gouvernement et du
ministre qui est présenté devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
et donc je n'interviens ici que comme
responsable de la sncf qui est
l'opérateur public national de transport
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté je
m'exprimerai de ce point de vue là et de
ce point de vue là seulement peut-être
pour utiliser la dizaine de minutes que
vous me proposez je voudrais essayer de
dire si le parlement adopte une réforme
du système ferroviaire dans les
prochaines semaines qu'est ce que la
sncf peut elle-même à pau
t avec cette réforme est donc avec votre
autorisation je n'entrerai pas dans le
détail de la proposition que fait le
gouvernement au parlement je pense que
c'est pas mon rôle je suis pas là pour
la défendre ou la critiquer ou l'amender
ça c'est le rôle du gouvernement et du
parlement en revanche ce que je peux
dire c'est ce que la sncf devrait faire
si cette réforme est adoptée et au fond
les choses me semble-t-il de ce point de
vue là sont sont assez claires d'abord
c'est à nos yeux d'opérateur ferroviaire
c'est une réforme qui est fait qui doit
être fait pour améliorer la vie des
voyageurs et des chargeurs il faut
jamais perdre de vue cet objectif
central c'est de rendre un meilleur
service public ferroviaire et je pense
que c'est ce que le pays attend de la
sncf
si la réforme est votée très
concrètement dès lors qu'il ya un
nouveau fonctionnement qui est prévu qu
est ce que nous allons faire un des
travaux mieux organisés et tout le monde
sait qu'il ya un mur de travaux sur le
réseau aujourd'hui 2 une vraie cohérence
système ça veut dire une préoccupation
constante de réaliser le meilleur lien
entre l'infrastructure et le ou les
transporteurs vous avez cité la sphère
du régiolis j'imagine qu'on reviendra
tout à l'heure et puis et puis le plus
important améliorer l'utilisation du
réseau on a un et un seul réseau serait
de ce réseau doit se partager entre eux
des travaux sa maintenance son
amélioration et puis des circulations et
pour avoir vécu ces quinze dernières
années deux établissements publics de
l'état qui étaient face à face au lieu
d'être
côte à côte et qui se sont livrés c'est
vrai pendant certaines années à une
guerre ouverte
on voit bien que l'utilisation du réseau
n'était pas optimal tout le monde
connais des tas d'exemples où des
travaux prévus annulait des trains mais
finalement les travaux n'avaient pas
lieu
et tout le monde connaît des trains qui
devaient circuler empêchant des travaux
mais finalement le train ne circulait
pas et donc de l'avis général le réseau
ferroviaire français est sous utilisé
faute de coordination entre ceux qui à
celui qui a la charge du réseau et ceux
qui en ont la charge de faire des
transports en termes chiffrés
si la réforme est adoptée par le
parlement moi je m'engagerai à ce que la
régularité des trains augmente
je dirais d'un point supplémentaire tous
les deux ans c'est à dire un demi point
par an sur les quatre à cinq ans qui
viennent
c'est un pari audacieux parce qu'on est
dans une période de travaux tous azimuts
mais je suis tellement convaincu qu'on
peut mieux faire fonctionner le système
que je prendrais cet engagement d'un
demi point de régularité supplémentaires
par an chaque année
deuxièmement pour les élus alors là les
choses n'en particulièrement frappante
tous les élus de france ont vécu ces
dernières années
l'incroyable complexité du système
ferroviaire dans lequel les élus sont
ballottés renvoyé de gares et connexions
vers l'infrastructure de
l'infrastructure vers le transporteur
bon ce n'est pas décent ça n'est pas
efficace ça a bloqué un nombre
considérable de projets d'aménagement
urbain et fonciers et par conséquent
l'engagement que je prends devant vous
si la réforme est votée c'est que nous
allons unifier la gestion du patrimoine
foncier et immobilier immédiatement
immédiatement c'est à dire que au delà
du régime juridique au delà des
personnes juridiques
nous allons faire dès le lendemain de la
réforme avec jacques rapoport un plateau
commun qui sera l'interlocuteur unique
de tous les élus au plan local et
national
pour simplifier les problèmes de foncier
et d'immobilier il y aurait bien
d'autres exemples à donner mais celui là
est celui qui me paraît le plus frappant
donc simplifier la vie des élus et des
collectivités pour accélérer les
opérations d'aménagement est évidemment
derrière tout ça il ya la valorisation
pour le logement social les équipements
collet
tif et il ya un meilleur traitement des
délaissés vous témoigner tous que dans
toutes les agglomérations dans toutes
les villes il ya des délaissés
ferroviaire qui sont dans un état pas
possible qu'ils posent des problèmes aux
élus et sur lesquels nous allons nous
engager vis-à-vis de vous à les traiter
lorsque la réforme sera votée troisième
point de vue cette fois ci que peu
comment peut-on s'engager vis-à-vis des
autorités organisatrices moins ce que
j'espère c'est que dans votre sagesse
vous ferez des autorités organisatrices
notamment régionale des autorités
organisatrices de plein exercice et
qu'on sortira du milieu du gué actuel où
on ne peut pas vraiment dire que celui
qui paye décide c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça chacun sait par exemple
que les tarifs des ter chaque année
l'augmentation des tarifs ter est fixé
dans une réunion interministérielle de
l'état mais s'applique aux régions c'est
un système qui est un peu paradoxale
chacun sait que juridiquement les trains
sont payés à 100% par les régions mais
n'appartiennent pas aux régions dont une
complexité qui est quand même assez
invraisemblable
donc oui il ya une simplification et une
clarification nécessaire autour de qui
paye décide et des autorités
organisatrices de plein exercice puisque
je m'exprime ici comme responsable de
l'opérateur indique aussi que sur la
question de la concurrence
l'union européenne a commencé à parler
puisque l'union européenne a adopté un
texte au parlement européen qui fixe d
échéance en 2019 et 2023
le texte proposé par le gouvernement ne
traite pas la question de la préparation
à la concurrence mais moi j'ai indique
qu'au vu de l'opérateur il faudra
ultérieurement traiter de cette question
car souvenons nous qu'en l'union
européenne a ouvert le fret à la
concurrence en 2007 2008 notre pays
était malheureusement totalement à me
préparer et donc le choc de l'ouverture
à la concurrence a été massif recul de
tous les trafics fret quasi faille
de fret sncf donc il faudra se préparer
à cette ouverture à la concurrence
par exemple les personnels nous
interroge sur une belle question la sncf
en 2023 père a marché que se passe-t-il
est ce que les personnels sncf qui
travaillent sur cette ligne sont
transférés au nouvel opérateur comme
c'est le cas dans les villes où est ce
que comme c'est le cas en allemagne
celui qui a perdu le marché récupère si
je puis dire l'ensemble de ses salariés
pour les affecter à d'autres lignes il y
a plusieurs systèmes possibles
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on ne peut pas
attendre que ça se produise en 2023 pour
avoir traité de cette question et je dis
simplement ce n'est pas l'urgence à on
est en 2023 mais il faudra aborder cette
question
quatrième point de vue le point de vue
économique avec jacques rapoport nous
nous partageons la même analyse
le projet de loi tel qu'il est permet
aux deux établissements publics de
stabiliser leur dette à une échéance qui
est probablement de l'ordre de 2020
permet de stabiliser la dette mais de la
stabiliser à un niveau très élevé c'est
donc une première étape
cette première étape elle est déjà
fondamental parce que comme l'a rappelé
notre président aujourd'hui sa dérive sa
dérive suivant le loyer de l'argent
entre un milliard et demi et 3 milliards
et suivant le nombre de projets de
grande vitesse
donc l'objectif de stabilité il est
ambitieux il suppose trois choses 1 que
notre pays réduisent la voilure sur les
nouveaux projets de lignes à grande
vitesse
non pas ceux qui sont en cours mais les
futurs la la commission duron mobilité
21 etc
2 il suppose que le système ferroviaire
fasse un effort de performance sans
précédent et avec jacques rapoport
nous nous engagerons
si la loi est votée nous nous engagerons
à faire un milliard d'euros d'économies
sur la facture ferroviaire de la france
en quelques années de l'ordre de 3 à 5
ans donc ça c'est l'engagement que nous
nous proposons de prendre de faire ce
milliard d'économies 500 millions du
côté du réseau 500 millions du côté de
l'entreprise de mobilité enfin la
troisième condition si je puis dire
c'est que l'état accompagne cette
stabilisation de la dette c'était une
question qui est en cours de discussion
et il m'appartient pas évidemment ici de
la commenter sur la façon dont l'état
pourrait ou ou pourrait ne pas
accompagner cette étape mais ce point de
vue là est absolument essentiel car s'il
n'y avait pas cet objectif de
stabilisation de la dette la réforme
n'atteindrait pas l'objectif de
consolider le système ferroviaire
je dis en toute honnêteté que je pense
qu'il y aura d'autres étapes après c'est
une première étape de stabiliser il y en
aura d'autres mais faisons déjà celle là
elle est ambitieuse
quatrième point de vue le point de vue
social je disais tout à l'heure on ne
peut pas préparer l'avenir du système
ferroviaire en faisant l'impasse sur les
règles sociales du système à ce moment
là ça veut dire des cheminots sont là
la variable d'ajustement et qu'au fond
on laisse les questions des salariés
sans réponse le projet de loi de ce
point de vue là comporte une disposition
fondamentale maintien du statut pour les
cheminots qui sont au statut comme
d'ailleurs à aider f à la météo dans
toutes les réformes législatives de
notre pays le statut des personnels en
place a été maintenu et deuxième partie
du projet de loi prescription par la loi
de la négociation d'une convention
collective applicable à 100 % des
salariés du secteur
mention collective elle fixe elle les
règles d'emploi la façon dont on fait
les 35 heures les amplitudes les repos
tout ce qui fait la vie quotidienne des
cheminots du public ou des cheminots du
privé cette disposition là nous la
soutenons avec jacques rapoport
fermement parce que nous il nous semble
que c'est la préparation de l'avenir
pour l'information du sénat cette
discussion s'est déjà amorcée sept
syndicats sont autour de la table
sept syndicats tous les salariés sont
représentés et nous avons déjà obtenu ce
qui est un point fondamental
nous avons déjà obtenu un accord de
méthode ce qui est un premier pas très
important cela signifie que les
syndicats et le patronat se sont engagés
sous l'autorité de l'état dans cette
négociation en partageant les objectifs
en partageant la façon de négocier
donc c'est quand même de bonne augure
même si chacun sait que ça sera
compliqué enfin ils pourront pas être
trop long deux autres petites
annotations d'abord la question
européenne
dans cette même salle je me souviens
lors de mon audition pour mon
renouvellement nous avions parlé de ces
questions et je me souviens que on était
dans la situation où il nous semblait
que l'union européenne avait pris des
positions très tranchées un peu
dogmatique en disons seule la séparation
sera acceptée à terme dans l'ordre la
france avec l'allemagne a joué son rôle
la france par la négociation l'allemagne
plus tôt par le rapport de force et le
vote du parlement européen qui est
intervenu en février laissent les deux
systèmes ouverts en europe le système
intégré que vous vous apprêtez à
examiner et un système séparé que
d'autres pays ont choisi et ces deux
systèmes sont jugés possibles par
l'europe à la condition qu'il y ait un
régulateur
tant mieux vive la raf il ya une arraf
en france et c'est un bien qui est un
régulateur du système ferroviaire et
deuxième condition
ceux qui ont choisi l'unité respecte le
principe de non discrimination des
entreprises privées ferroviaire et
j'indique ici que et jacques rapoport et
moi même nous sommes totalement engagés
à respecter le principe de non
discrimination des entreprises privées
ferroviaire et nous le ferons parce que
c'est la condition d'existence d'un
système intégré dernier mot peut-être et
qui est pas le moins important pour nous
qu'est ce que cette réforme si vous la
beauté peut apporter à l'activité à
l'exportation et à l'emploi et pour moi
ça c'est un point essentiel
on ne le sait pas mais la sncf est un
champion industriel français européen et
international elle fait aujourd'hui
presque 10 milliards de volume
d'affaires hors de france
pour certaines de ses activités
les activités logistiques les activités
de métro de tramway la moitié de notre
activité est fait en europe ou ailleurs
dans le monde et nous sommes le deuxième
groupe mondial de services de mobilité
derrière le groupe allemand deutsche
bahn ces activités sont en très forte
croissance car dont le monde entier
l'urbanisation les grandes métropoles
exigent des solutions écologiques et
acceptables en termes énergétiques de
transport et de déplacement et donc ces
activités sont vitales dans le monde
entier et c'est un des points forts de
notre pays et en n'ayant une
organisation nouvelle du système
ferroviaire nous agirons comme pardon du
mot qui est un peu barbare un acteur du
système ferroviaire parce qu'on ne vende
pas le savoir faire français en tranches
de salami
on apporte des solutions à des villes à
des entreprises en leur disant oui nous
savons nous des français faire un
tram-train qui at-elle caractéristiques
et le système entier et nous arrivons
avec des oeufs
i française nous arrivons et des
entreprises de génie civil nous arrivons
avec des constructeurs de matériel
français est donc cette dimension
offensive de champions industriels
c'est me semble-t-il la finalité des
finalités pour vous citer une anecdote
un jour la chancelière allemande à
l'occasion de nous rencontrer un certain
nombre d'entre nous et nous a dit mais
vous savez en allemagne la deutsche bahn
son fonctionnement
c'est un consensus politique en
allemagne
quelles que soient les coalitions le
fait d'avoir un champion industriel
allemand
elle n'a pas cité le lien avec siemens
mais elle aurait pu citer aussi le lien
avec siemens en disant tout ça ça permet
à l'allemagne de jouer un rôle
prépondérant dans le six dans les
systèmes de transport en europe et dans
le monde et donc cette dimension là qui
est créatrice d'emplois qui équilibre le
commerce extérieur qui est créatrice de
croissance c'est une finalité
extraordinairement importante
voilà ce que je voulais dire en
introduction monsieur le président en
tête était un tout petit peu trop long
première question est posée par monsieur
michel teston merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président pepy je
vais chez ne pas être trop long mais
toutefois je souhaite quand même vous
poser quatre questions 2 qui porte sur
l'organisation actuelle et les missions
actuelles la sncf une qui est relative
aux relations avec les régions qui sont
très investis en tant qu'autorité
organisatrice des trains express
régionaux et je ne vous poseraient
qu'une seule question sur le projet de
réforme ferroviaire pour laisser aux
collègues la possibilité de s'exprimer
largement cette question malgré tout et
centrale vous l'avez évoqué c'est celle
de l'aspect financier de la réforme
ferroviaire
alors d'abord première question qui
concerne finalement l'organisation
actuelle j'ai mené en tant que
rapporteur du projet de réforme
ferroviaire de très nombreuses auditions
depuis plusieurs mois et gt
frapper ainsi que celles et ceux qui ont
participé à ces auditions par les
critiques formulées par un certain
nombre d'interlocuteurs sur la gestion
par activité qui selon ces personnes
aurait profondément désorganisé
l'entreprise
alors je citerai un exemple qui est
souvent cité il y aurait une grande
difficulté pour ne pas dire une
impossibilité pour un conducteur
affectés à l'activité fret de pouvoir en
cas de nécessité
conduiront ter même si ledit conducteur
à toutes les habilitations pour conduire
en train donc autorisés à circuler à 160
kilomètres heure ce qui est le cas pour
les ter
deuxième question vous êtes chargé par
convention avec l'état de la mission
essentielle en matière d'aménagement du
territoire des trains d'équilibré du
territoire
or ces trains sont très peu fréquenté et
ils ne sont peu en raison de leur manque
d'attractivité matériel roulant ancien
horaires mal adapté alors que comptez
vous faire pour finalement les rendre
attractifs à l'instar de ce qui est fait
dans de très nombreuses autres états de
l'union européenne où le terme trains
d'équilibré du territoire n'existe pas
mais où ces trêves existe par contre
bien troisième question elle me
permettra de faire la transition avec le
projet de loi de réforme ferroviaire
c'est la situation avec la question donc
du projet de réforme ferroviaire et la
situation financière du système
ferroviaire
c'est la place des régions dans le
dispositif quand on regarde le projet de
loi dans sa forme initiale
finalement la place des régions n'est
que peu reconnu et alors quelques
avancées sont possibles à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
quelques-unes ont été esquissés à ma
connaissance la semaine dernière lors de
l'examen par la commission durable de
l'assemblée nationale donc du côté de la
sncf que comptez vous faire pour
répondre aux critiques des régions et en
particulier sur le manque de
transparence
de vos comptes et puis la dernière
question est au coeur de la réforme
ferroviaire qui s'engagent dans un
contexte un peu pesant semble-t-il si
l'on en croit les informations sur des
préavis de grève qui aurait été déposée
par deux organisations syndicales
représentatives
la question financière est bien un
élément central de la réforme
or je dois dire que malgré les
informations que nous avait donnée celle
donnée par le président de rff celle
donnée par le secrétaire d'état aux
transports
la plupart les interlocuteurs auditions
n'ont pas été convaincus du tout par les
économies annoncées et attendues
finalement de la réforme
donc le fait qu'on me constitue un
gestionnaire unifiée d'infrastructures
en regroupant sncf infra la dcf et puis
rff ne leur paraît pas finalement
suffisant pour assurer les économies
attendues et donc ses interlocuteurs en
quelques doutes sur la stabilisation de
la dette avec les avait fait allusion
dans trois ou quatre ans
même si effectivement cette
stabilisation mais vous l'avez dit
devrait se situer à un très haut niveau
ce qui pose le problème de savoir sur la
part de la dette du système ferroviaire
et en particulier de rff
s'il n'y a pas une dette d'état mais
c'est une autre question qu'on abordera
pas aujourd'hui puisqu'elle nous dépasse
pour l'instant voilà je n'ai pas été
trop longs monsieur le président de la
commission sur le président de la sncf
je pense que les collègues poseront de
nombreuses questions que j'aurais posé
mais il est normal que vous leur laisser
la possibilité de s'exprimer
merci monsieur testons monsieur louis
bien monsieur le président
messieurs les présidents le
monsieur testons par le d'or le climat
est pesant
il est pesant et c'est pas la faute à
michel ni à louis on constate que nous
avons aujourd'hui un préavis de grève
donc cette réforme qui est fait par un
gouvernement de gauche ne recueille pas
semble-t-il l'assentiment de sa basse
c'est déjà un problème politique c'est
un problème politique
d'abord j'ai encore j'ai encore le droit
d'exprimer mon opinion michel alors
allons messieurs c'est l'accès c'est pas
un duo c'est pas un duo mais c'est une
question la parole à monsieur louis
neige explique michel que les agitations
du all à 1
s'il vous plaît monsieur neil vous
reprenez le film mais votre question est
si monsieur le président
voilà donc que nous avons déjà un
contexte qui n'est pas porteur à ce
niveau là qui pose problème parce que y
compris la base renâcle
mais il n'ya pas que la base parce que
si on prend cette réforme attendue je
pense que et quand j'emploie le mot
attendue elle est attendue par tout le
monde
les assises du ferroviaire ont bien
montré tout l'intérêt de s'engager dans
une réforme et là c'était consensuelle
il faut une réforme qu'elle est la
réforme qu'on doit faire c'est là dessus
ou peut-être on se divisera moi ce que
je constate c'est que dès lors que l'on
met en place un état stratège ça me
convient je trouve que à ce niveau là et
notamment au niveau du réseau mais ça va
avoir des incidences dans ma démarche
parce qu'à ce moment là le président du
directoire c'est le président du réseau
après vous avez une validation par le
parlement qui est souhaitable d'une
vision globale comme on le trouve en
allemagne où vous avez tous les cinq ans
la possibilité de remettre à niveau
votre plan et en tout état de cause qu
il y ait une validation j'allais dire
annuel c'est quelque chose qui passerait
par le parlement et qui me paraît
nécessaire
pour atteindre cette fameuse
transparence la réunification du gym
très bien tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus on a le sentiment vraiment qu'il
fallait se rassemblent et qu'il fallait
mettre les équipes ensemble pour arriver
à de meilleurs résultats
ensuite je reprendrai ce qui a été dit
par michel teston la place des régions
me laisse songeur je n'ai pas très bien
compris où elle est et ce qu'elle
pouvait faire
elle manque d'argent en plus mais je
pense que les régions mérite d'être des
autorités de plein exercice et je vous
rejoins sur ce point là je pense qu'il
faut à partir de là leur donner les
moyens de leur politique pour qu'on soit
cohérent avec nous mêmes on a également
alors maintenant dans les questions que
je pourrais poser pour faire vite
je trouve malheureusement un certain
nombre de problèmes premier c'est avec
la raf avec ce fameux régulateur que
tout le monde attend appels de nos voeux
et à qui d'entrée de jeu on coupe les
ailes
il a plus d'avis qu'en forme il a plus
qu'un avis motivé voilà donc voilà
quelque chose qui moi m'interpelle
directement je les dis au ministre en
personne
j'ai dit attends je comprends pas bon
ensuite la dette la dette c'est un sujet
non négligeable et bien la dette vous
vous engagez me dites vous pour 1
milliard d'économies en quelques années
si on arrive et je vous remercie pour
votre méthode et intellectuelle si on
arrive à stabiliser cette dette ce sera
déjà un grand progrès voilà où nous en
sommes en france aujourd'hui
la dette est en dizaines de milliards
d'euros
et tout ce qu'on peut viser aujourd'hui
dans le meilleur des cas
évincé la stabilisation de la dette je
vous parle pas de la résolution du
problème qui est la dette
personne n'en parle et pourtant tout le
monde sait que ça c'est un vrai problème
de fond et qu'il apparaît
pas du tout bon ensuite vous avez ce que
l'europe appelé donc c'est un corollaire
avec le jus
c'est ce qu'on a appelé les murailles de
chine cette indépendance de ce
groupement d infrastructure unifiée et
bien si nous n'avons pas la garantie
d'une autonomie et d'une indépendance
des flux financiers
je serai je m'opposerai à ce type de
réforme je pense qu'il est souhaitable
et nécessaire qu'il y ait là de
véritable muraille de chine
particulièrement impénétrables il me
restera ensuite à vous poser la question
de savoir où vous situez les élus et les
usagers dans cette démarche là parce que
j'estime que les élus et notamment les
parlementaires le parlement qui vote les
réformes qui votent les lois qu'ils
votent le budget qui vous permet de 10
ans d'avoir ensuite un budget en
équilibre en fin d'année a besoin ils
ont besoin ces élus d'avoir leur place
et je le souhaite également ardemment
les usagers nous nous sommes tous tous
au service de nos concitoyens et donc je
souhaiterais les retrouver et ensuite
une petite question de taquine
que devient la gouvernance des gares
monsieur françois grignon francis
grignon c'est pas grave
merci monsieur le président
alors en préambule je voudrais dire que
pour bien m'imprégner de cette réforme
et pour faire des comparaisons
j'ai interrogé des responsables de la db
aussi parce que nos deux grands
champions et en allemand et français
je trouve qu'il était intéressant de
faire des comparaisons alors je voudrais
aborder le problème sous deux angles ce
qui est dans la loi et ce qui est hors
la loi ce qui hors la loi je veux dire
ce qui est en dehors de la loi partout
excuse moi alors ce qui est dans la loi
j'avais des doutes au départ sur la
gouvernance avec deux personnes
directoire bien et à la réflexion quand
je regarde ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne on a en fait le comité db à
gué et mobility logistique aguets on a
là bas deux groupes mais avec le même
directeur
on a deux groupes parce qu'à l'époque
fausse le rappeler en allemagne on
voulait privatiser l'activité de
l'opérateur ferroviaire le faire entrer
en bourse
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette idée on
aurait qu'un seul groupe donc moi il me
semble que ce qui est prévu dans notre
loi aujourd'hui est tout à fait cohérent
par rapport à ce qui se passe en
allemagne et que nous n'avons pas à
faire plus séparés ce qui nous
pénaliserait par rapport à eux et comme
nous sommes les deux grands en europe
moi je trouve que c'est quand même pas
mal deuxièmement la rafale au départ
dans le texte on j'étais un peu choqué
par le rôle de la raf qui n'avait plus
que 1 avis qu'ils n'étaient pas
conformes mais je crois que tout a été
rectifiée je pense que c'est à la
satisfaction de tout le monde et que la
raf retrouve son rôle
troisième sujet le transfert au aux
réseaux de toutes les infrastructures
qui sont en particulier chez sncf
mobilité aujourd'hui j'aimerais avoir
les lacets une question sur le président
j'aimerais savoir si tout est bien
transféré pour qu'il n'y ait pas la
tentation de certains de faire des
blocages sur le terrain assez insidieux
parfois et je pose en particulier le
problème des cours de marchandises pour
que les opérateurs de fret puissiez
accéder librement facilement sans aucune
contrainte
ainsi que le problème des facilités
essentielles
en ce qui concerne ce qui est plutôt
hors la loi ou qui n'est pas traitée
dans la loi par dont il ya le problème
de la dette on l'a dit 42 milliards si
vous pouviez me confirmer 35 pour rff 7
pour la sncf je dis simplement mes
collègues que chez la db pour un chiffre
d'affaires plus important c'est 17
milliards donc j'espère qu'on ait ce
chiffre en comparaison donc j'espère
j'espère que l'état va continuer à
garantir cette chose sinon